officiellement le public vient assister
à un événement de promotion littéraire
medec l'auteur arrive on comprend
rapidement qu'il s'agit d'un
rassemblement politique
une salle comble pour entendre eric
zemmour polémiste d'extrême droite et
possible candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
c'est pas un politicien
comme les autres c'est quelqu'un qui
sait résister parfois seul contre tous
contre ret pensée de gauche à laquelle
la droite est traditionnellement
soumises
journaliste auteur commentateurs eric
zemmour qui promet de rendre sa grandeur
à la france se démarque depuis des
années par ses positions controversées
l'ancien éditorialiste du figaro se dit
philosophiquement en accord avec la
peine de mort critique féminisme mais sa
grande préoccupation est surtout
l'immigration condamné par la justice
dans le passé pour incitation à la haine
il n'hésite pas à parler de grand
remplacement par les musulmans et du
besoin d'assimiler et nouveaux arrivants
il n'est pas officiellement déclaré et
pourtant eric zemmour soit l'attention
médiatique d'un véritable candidat et
sondeurs mesure ses appuis à la
télévision et dans les journaux on
rapporte presque tout ce qu'il dit il ya
tout un tas de façons parler de lui est
ce que on fait du fact checking
systématique sur toutes ces erreurs
historiques et il y en a beaucoup a
relevé sur toutes ces approximations on
peut mais ça nous conte sa nous condamne
à faire 5 des articles par jour sur lui
cet expert des médias et de la droite
radicale revient sur un exemple qui a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre cette
semaine
en visitant le salon de sécurité et
l'eczéma aura pointé une arme vers des
journalistes affirmant faire une blague
un geste qui a soulevé un tollé des
idées des provocations qui sont les
siennes aujourd'hui moi je les compare
radicale mais si vous savez pas la
différence entre l'humour la blague et
le sérieux c'est que vous êtes investis
et provoquer le dégoût la détestation
soit en les petites phrases de donald
trump connaît très très bien soit en
braquant une arme vers les journalistes
façon complètement grotesque parce que
assumer ça ça pouvait paradoxalement
vous amis du crédit et vous amener des
soutiens au delà des critiques la
présence d'eric zemmour sur la scène
publique place certains politiciens sur
la défensive comme marine le pen que le
polémiste talonne maintenant dans les
sondages c'est peut-être moins sexy pour
les journalistes mais je crois que c'est
ce qu'attendent en l'occurrence les
français de la publicité du travail du
sérieux du long terme surtout parmi les
sympathisants du polémiste certains
accusent marine le pen et son parti de
s'être trop recentrer d'avoir fait trop
de compromis le rationnel c'est beaucoup
décrédibiliser au cours des vingt années
avec un discours souvent fluctuant et
régler moore fait tout de même face à
son lot de difficultés sans parti
atteindre la présidence demeure un grand
défi mais il se targue déjà d'une
première victoire avoir forcé les autres
candidats à se prononcer sur certains de
ses thèmes prioritaires comme
l'immigration et la sécurité
sans même qu'on sache c'est sera du
scrutin dans six mois le polémiste a
déjà réussi à bousculer l'échiquier
politique français ici rafale bouvier
auclair radio-canada à versailles